rising from the sand and the sea
Katara's latest World Cup Stadium is
coming to life one shipping container at
a time sustainability is the main focus
for those building but us abou a food
stadium in Doha all its components are
recyclable and the life-size building
blocks are arriving to port filled with
all the materials that will eventually
hold them together inside the stadium do
you know that it's a container stadium
can you tell from the inside from inside
they will notice mainly the hospitality
boxes which will have the finish of the
container the containers will be used to
make up everything from the stadium's
bathrooms offices and restaurants but
always with an eye on sustainability
what we have considered from the very
early stages in the design that every
single component of the stadium whether
it's a container or the steel structure
that will hold the containers and the
roof as well we consider from the early
stages in the design how this can be
reused the project is expected to be
finished by the end of next year once
completed it will be the first fully
dismantle FIFA World Cup Stadium and one
of seven being built just for 2022 these
are the first containers to arrive 92 of
them just came in from China and a
thousand are expected in total after the
World Cup this stadium will be
disassembled and these containers will
be used to build another stadium
somewhere else in the world it's truly a
case of thinking outside the box part of
Qatar's bid for hosting the 2022 games
involved a plan to help another country
develop its sporting facilities the
40,000 seat stadium can be moved and
split into two or made into an arena
could be a good opportunity for those
countries to offer too we utilize the
whole facility that we're gonna build
here
guitar has already delivered one of its
World Cup venues this year that algae
noob Stadium and Al Walker those behind
the rows of what Abood project say it
will cost twenty percent less than other
traditional stadiums and piece by piece
along Doha's waterfront it's starting to
come together
Lea Harding al Jazeera Doha